when you're in a business relationship
you're in a marriage and their
extracurricular life is going to get
dragged into the business i promise you
in this video i want to give you the
keys to having a terrible terrible
partnership and the reason we're talking
about in this perspective is because my
my my big hero charlie munger talked
about inverted thinking as one of the
best ways to solve problems so rather
than think how do i have an amazing
partnership let's think about how would
i guarantee a miserable terrible
partnership that would uh definitely
ensue in a terrible breakup with lots of
lawyers and all the paperwork and just
honestly ideally take forever and result
in no benefit all right and if you don't
know hi my name is alex shimozzi i own
acquisition.com it's a portfolio of
companies over 100 million a year and i
have nothing to sell you i make these
videos because i hope that you make lots
and lots of money from them and then
hopefully you apply to become a
portfolio company with us as long as
you're doing you know three to let's say
20 million dollars a year and ideally an
internet business now that being said
let's rock and roll on how to have a
terrible partnership now as somebody who
has a lot of partnerships um it has
taken me a very long time to get here
and i have learned a lot along the way
and the beauty of having stories is that
you can get the lessons without the
scars and so i will give you let's see
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten ten different things that you
can do to guarantee absolutely atrocious
terrible partnership that you wish you
could just not live anymore right that
is that's what's gonna happen if we can
make this partnership as terrible as
we're gonna shoot for here all right so
number one is that we're gonna make sure
that they have the exact same knowledge
base as you all right so this person
that you're gonna do business with knows
the exact same stuff at you there's no
stuff that they know that you don't know
all right because that way one of you is
unnecessary all right and so this is a
great way to have a terrible start to a
partnership one of you being unnecessary
to begin with which means both of you
are giving away half your equity for no
incremental benefit it's also not very
good for the business because why would
you do that so that being said number
one have the same knowledge base and
maybe even if we're being crazy which we
are right throw into the same
experiences right if you both worked at
the same place doing the same thing why
not start a business together doing the
exact same thing brilliant i know all
right so number two is time right make
sure that uh they have the same amount
of time as you all right or
disproportionate and what i mean there
is the big three on partnerships is
knowledge money time right which means
they either have to have knowledge you
don't have they got to have money you
don't have or they got to have time you
don't have right and so if you have no
time make sure they don't have time too
right now if you do have time and they
have time then you're fine but the thing
is is then you'd have to look at one of
the other three parts of this equation
in order to make sure that it's still a
terrible partnership all right so make
sure that you're misaligned on time all
right the next one is money if you're
getting to a partnership if uh one of
you has money and the other doesn't then
that's value that's being out of the
relationship but if uh you're going to
partner with somebody and they don't
have money that you don't have they
don't have knowledge that you don't have
and they don't have time they don't have
then why would you do the partnership i
don't know but it is a great way to have
a terrible partnership which is what the
purpose of this video is now that being
said let's say that somehow we still
figured out a way that we got in a
relationship where one of us didn't have
the knowledge of the time we didn't have
the money that the other person had we
got together okay cool there's still
more ways that we can we can torpedo
this thing just wait buckle up so the
next one is that we can make sure that
we have different expectations of one
another and the business all right so
it's like hey what do i expect you to do
what do you expect me to do right and
those expectations we want to make sure
and this is number five is that there's
no agreements we don't record it
anywhere we don't write it down we do it
on a handshake because we're old school
yeah great way to have a terrible
business relationship and the reason
that people don't want to do that is
because usually they don't want to have
the hard conversations all right they
don't want to say what happens if this
goes wrong right and like what do you
expect you really expect me to take the
trash out every day like they want to
have this unspoken expectation you have
unspoken expectations of you know what's
going to be magical where you you don't
actually have to have hard conversations
with people and if you can't have a hard
conversation with a partner before even
doing business before you are even
married before you there is even money
or stakes on the table or equity value
that's been grown then dear god you're
not gonna have a good conversation at
the end all right so if someone's like i
don't do agreements just walk away i
just i've been doing this like just walk
away it's only like very very very weird
people do that like banks banks don't
just give you money without expecting
like come on like this is real world and
i used to think i remember earlier on i
i heard someone tell me that and i was
like oh i don't want to be the guy he's
like i'm the type of person that if you
can't uh shake your hand then blah blah
and i just i just don't i just don't
trust people that much so the idea for
me is make sure the paper says we need
to say but then trust the person right
which is like i hope that we never have
like we write these contracts with the
intention of never having to look at
them right but we still use the contract
as a vehicle to facilitate dialogue
around difficult topics and to have
shared expectations in a way that we
both understand them and agree right
that is the purpose of the contract it's
not to get lawyers involved purpose of
the contract is that we have clear
expectations that is why contracts exist
clear expectations on agreements all
right so if we're making sure that we
have a terrible partnership we got to
have all the same knowledge we got to
have disproportionate time or money
right so all those things time money
knowledge we're we're all matched on
those which means that one of us isn't
necessary on top of that we have
different expectations we didn't write
it down so there's no agreements and
there's no expectations that's been
communicated about what you're gonna do
what i'm gonna do all right now the next
one this big one give away everything
all right so make sure that you give
away everything in the partnership and
do a disproportionate amount of work at
the onset because that way you'll just
definitely make sure that you can garner
a resentment towards the other person
and the flip side can be true too if you
know the other person doing a lot of
work uh then you think yourself oh well
i'm going to squeeze as much out of them
as i possibly can what's going to happen
they're going to resent you and they're
going to try and renegotiate later once
reality sets in so if you can think a
few steps ahead of the person rather
than saying like oh i'm going to get
them just say like hey i don't know if
this is going to be equitable in the
future like give them more and you'll
actually start to create a relationship
rather than a negotiated contractual
agreement which at the end of the day
that's all contracts are supposed to do
is just outline the expectations between
two parties that's it all right now the
next one is that we want to make sure
that we have not we won't have a
misaligned three things mission values
and vision all right which means that we
don't actually want to take this
business to the same place and this may
sound hilarious to you but you would be
amazed at the amount of partners that we
get on the phone with that i'm like what
do you guys want to do this business and
what person's like i think we should go
this way the other was like i think we
should go that way i'm like i think that
you should figure that out right or one
of you shouldn't be here right figure it
out all right which is where do we want
to go and the next one is the values
which is how we're going to get there
right what are the things that are
important to us about how we deal with
other humans right what are those values
and if some people have different values
becomes very difficult to do business
even if you want to accomplish it the
same thing because you want to do it
different ways right and then it'll
create endless strife and conflict
throughout now the last one is what you
consider lifestyle right which is what
do you uh similar interests lifestyle uh
it's very difficult to do business with
somebody if you're like you're a dave
ramsey saver and you you know you're you
live far below your means and you're
doing business with somebody who lives
far above their means and goes into debt
all the time because the thing is is
when you're in a business relationship
you're in a marriage and their
extracurricular life is going to get
dragged into the business i promise you
i promise you it is going to get dragged
in right and so you've got to look just
like you uh you marry the girl you marry
the family that whole thing um it's the
same thing with business if like they've
got all this crazy stuff going on in
their personal life it's a great way to
guarantee that that stuff is going to
trickle into your business and the thing
is is if you have an unreliable partner
creates an unreliable relationship which
creates an unreliable business and so
it's a great way to have a terrible
partnership all right and so when we're
thinking about partners big picture i
give you two frameworks and then some
in-betweens so framework one is that
they got to have knowledge money or time
that you don't have if both of you have
the exact same experience knowledge time
and money one of you isn't required i
know crazy the thing is is just because
you need something for example if i need
an accountant for business doesn't mean
i have to partner with my accountant it
means i have to pay them for services so
just because you have a need doesn't
mean they have to have equity all right
it's a big aha moment here if you're
like well i don't know how to do that he
does it's like well can you pay someone
to do it like equity is the most
expensive thing that you give up in a
relationship so you want to make sure if
you especially want to build something
big then you're giving away equity to
people who are going to really drive the
growth and you have to see this thing 10
years in the future which no one thinks
10 years in the future anyways which is
why everyone's small okay so boom so
knowledge money time you got to check
those boxes make sure that you're
aligned there next one is expectations
agreements all right make sure that
they're equitable make sure that they're
well understood and making sure that
they're documented right if you do those
things then it's very very it's much
less likely that you're gonna have a
terrible partnership you can still have
one but it's much less likely all right
and point of this video is to guarantee
a terrible partnership all right now the
next big framework is that mission
values and similar interests it actually
works the same way in marriages as does
in partnerships and to be real it's very
similar so you got to make sure that you
want to do the same thing with the
business big picture you got to make
sure you want to do it the same way
right and then you got to have similar
interests and lifestyles right which is
making sure that they don't have a messy
life which is you want to be proud to
associate with the other person that
you're doing business with and i'm
saying proud not okay with but proud to
associate with them you want other
people to meet them just like you want
to meet you know the girl meets the
parents you want to be proud to present
this person not like that crap right big
picture great ways to guarantee a
terrible partnership is if you do all
those things all right so on the flip
side make sure that they have time money
and knowledge that you don't have right
either they got money you don't have
they got time you don't have they don't
they have knowledge you don't have or
experience right so they can bring
something table you don't have so one of
you or both of you are required and that
the company grows based on the shared
skill sets that both of you have all
right you want to make sure that you set
expectations that you document them and
then you make sure that they're
equitable all right because if you do
that then it's very unlikely that you're
going to fail all right and the next one
is that you want to make sure that
there's aligned mission values and
similar interests you want to deal with
the types of people who see the world
the same way as you have the biggest
long-term goals and they want to do the
process of getting from where you are to
where you want to go the same way you do
and the easiest litmus test is if you
present both of you with the same data
would you make the same decision if
these answers yes then you'll have far
less conflict in your partnership over
the long haul and so the idea is can i
find people who have complementary skill
sets but align mission values and
interests if you can do that you can
make room for a magical rather than
terrible partnership all right keeping
awesome donation lots of love and i'll
catch you guys next video bye
moseynation if you enjoyed that video
smash the subscribe button and hit the
little notification bell the reason for
that is because i don't actually have a
cadence when i make these videos so if
you want to make sure you don't miss the
next one that comes out go subscribe
notify and i'll see you the next one bye